what I'd say is this is probably in the
first party realm so far the biggest
test Game Pass is gonna face in my eyes
like this is gonna be the real moment we
all learn the virality of it does dirty
matter does the negative Twitter yapping
does that matter does any of this matter
or are we kind of in our own bubble here
and I think it's a good one to pay
attention to because I think Xbox is
going to rock with it I don't think
they're gonna delay the game I don't
want to say all that because I think
they're they're looking at this scene
all right we're gonna see what this hat
if this works out really well and we
have the highest player count ever for
an Arcane game you know that's what
Phil's always talked about with
bethesda's game studios we want
Starfield to be the most played Bethesda
game he never says highest selling so
that turns out to be by their mattress a
success for redfall then they're gonna
feel really cool calm collected going
into starfield's launch and as long as
they're gaining Game Pass Subs maybe
they don't care
um I completely agree though that you
want